new york post let's just look at this
for a second is this an acceptable way
to get back to the window seat on a
plane look at what happened here a woman
caught on a twitter video has sparked a
discussion on flight etiquette imagine
imagine being on the fence on this one
oh i don't know looks good to me really
after the clip showed her returning to
her seat in a rather questionable if not
rude way you don't say a twitter user by
the name of brandon shared the video of
the divisive act last week showing the
unidentified woman climbing over three
other people one of whom appears to be a
toddler
seated on an adult's lap
the crazy gets crazier
to get to her window seat all three of
them are awake and presumably could have
stood and moved to the aisle to make way
for her return okay so what's going on
here we all know the types i told you
about the sandwich i once was on an
airplane
i will never forget it woman started
clipping her toenails
i gave her that new york dagger look she
stopped she stopped i looked down and i
see just
nails on the floor
okay let's just say i didn't eat for the
rest of the flight
i have a comment on this that people
aren't gonna like first of all that's
rude right can we all just get get on
team bela on this one i know you like to
disagree with me it's something you
enjoy but can you just get on team billa
that maybe you don't take your socks off
you don't put your feet on top of the
chair you don't climb over other people
to get to the window seat hey excuse me
where are people's manners
why does everyone's manners even if you
have them they seem to just dissipate on
an airplane is there not enough oxygen
up there to get to the brain
don't get me started on that is there
not enough ventilation because we can't
open the windows do people go a little
meh are you secretly anxiety written
inside that tube in the middle of the
sky and you just you start just
climbing on people and like you're i
don't know you kind of like a
neanderthal again what is it
what is it
tyler do you do this do you climb on
people in the airplane do you get crazy
in an airplane no so i
she was doing this the whole time right
the whole quote the whole seven hour
flight but no i uh i when i go to fly
i wear nice clothes or a jacket i wear
you know a polo whatever you do you get
all dressed up i get all dressed up but
i'm actually we'll see if i ever
actually finished i'm just getting my
private pilot's license i'll fly my damn
self
and me and you'll fly yourself and me
and jeremy and hartley because i can't
that's very impressive by the way yeah
like pilots just get a pilot's license
it's 40 years
40 hours of flight lessons and you have
a problem you can run a plane you can
fly yourself there's a few things you
can't do but you can fly yourself during
the day in nice weather conditions
wherever the hell you want to go i'm
going to need tyler to fly for a little
more than 40 hours before i get in his
plane i'm just going to put that out
there a little more practice not saying
i don't trust you not saying i do
but yeah
okay so the airplane you know i'm gonna
say something now that's controversial
okay
women often it is you that behaves bad
that behave badly on these flights
i'm sorry to say it you look at that
picture
that woman did that a guy would not have
done that
now watch tyler's gonna pull a picture
of a guy doing that i i think women are
much like because they get away with it
right
if a woman did that
the guys are like oh man what's this
what's she doing what they don't even
know what to do they're like
frozen like just let's get her let's
just go get in your seat and let this
let this end
you tell me if a guy did that
he would not get away with that
there would be a lot of terms used there
would be a lot of there would be there
would be a lot going on so i think women
do this a lot i often the people i see
doing this stuff and we always think of
men as the grocer of the two like oh why
you gotta be so gross my husband i'm
always like why are you gonna do that
it's so gross and yet the woman clipping
her toenails on my flight a woman
oftentimes i'll see women putting their
feet up doing that stuff i'm not saying
men don't do it but
that stuff climbing on people i
guarantee you if you had to to take a a
survey of how many times it was a man
versus how many that's gonna be a lot of
women doing that stuff you get away with
it sometimes the cute women i'll tell
i'll say it
they get away with a lot they're like oh
i'm just going to walk all over you ha
ha and the guys are like hey what do i
do it's a whole moment that happens okay
uh you know big guy tries to do that
he's not going to get away with what the
cute little girl oh i'm dainty
you may be dainty don't step on me i
didn't invite you not only that can i
just say
her socks look very dirty at the bottom
very dirty she walked in those socks
to the bathroom picked up i don't know
what on the floor
look
there's video by the way down at the
bottom if you want to scroll and show
the video that's up to you but you see
the socks are dirty and she stepped all
over everybody if she had done that to
me there would have been words that's
all i'm gonna say the brooklyn would
have come out it would have been a scene
i'm not saying they would have had to
land the plane but one never does no
listen parents out there teach kids not
to do this
there she goes look at her look at the
bottoms of her feet
i cannot
teach your kids not to do this on
airplanes
adults don't lose your minds on an
airplane i know the oxygen is tight i
know i get it
you're in a hard vestibule in the middle
of the sky i get it i'm with you don't
lose your mind don't step on people
don't do this stuff
don't make this the generation that
loses manners completely
all right that's what i was originally
going to plan to get to before i had a
rant on pfizer i was all about the feat
by the way if you google
i don't know i don't know if i should
put this out there because tyler will do
it if you google like
feet on airplanes stuff comes up
okay stuff comes up that you may not
want to see unless you're a fan of the
feet we know who you are out there maybe
you'll like it i i don't need to see
everybody's feet but if you google it
it's there i'm doing it he's doing it
he's not playing yeah look okay take a
look at what's going on on airplanes
look feet everywhere up
people taking cell you know people have
cameras now
it's like
your foot famous look at this look what
people do on airplanes with their feet
can you explain this phenomenon to me
why this happens it shouldn't happen
i don't know man i can't and you know
what sometimes people's feet aren't that
cute let's talk about feet for a second
some people have cute feet some people
don't let's be real we'll have an honest
discussion
and some feats stink
you know it you know if your feet stink
don't take your socks off and pretend
they don't come on this one goes out to
the guys in particular i have to say
all right if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]